IS "BLOOMBERG WEST."
TESLA'S TINKERING UNDER THE WITH
BETTER BATTERIES AND AN OVERHAUL
OF AUTOPILOT.
AND WE WILL HEAR FROM
PITTSBURGH'S MAIL -- MAYOR ABOUT
THEIR PILOT UBER AND HOW
PITTSBURGH PLANS TO REMAKE
ITSELF AS A MANUFACTURING HUB OF
THE FUTURE.
AND THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
INTERNET IS ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS.
WE ARE TALKING TO THE COFOUNDERS
OF REDDIT, COVERING EVERY THING
FROM AD BLOCKING TECHNOLOGY TO
FREE SPEECH ON THE WEB.
FIRST, TO OUR LEAD -- ELON MUSK
IS THEM BEING UP TESLA MODEL'S
TELLING INVESTORS TO EXPECT NEW
VERSIONS WITH MORE POWERFUL
BATTERIES.
THEY CAN NOW COVER UP TO 315
MILES ON A SINGLE CHARGE.
ALSO APPEALING TO SPORTS CAR
ENTHUSIASTS SAYING THE IMPROVED
MODEL WOULD BE UP TO ACCELERATE
TO 60 MILES AN HOUR ZERO IN 2.5
SECONDS.
HERE TO BREAK DOWN THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THESE NEW
FEATURES IS DAVID WELCH FROM OUR
AUTO TEAM IN DETROIT.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT?
DAVID: WHAT HE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY IS MARGINAL AND KIND OF
INCREMENTAL, BUT THERE IS SOME
SIGNIFICANT MARKETING NEWS.
HE CAN SAY HE'S GOT THE FIRST
CAR THAT CAN GO OVER 300 MILES
ON A SINGLE CHARGE AND BRAGGED
THAT THE MODEL S IS GOING TO BE
THE FASTEST CAR IN THE WORLD YOU
CAN BUY AT RETAIL.
IT IS GOING TO BEAT FERRARI AND
PORSCHE AND IT IS AN ELECTRIC
CAR.
FROM HIS POINT OF VIEW, THIS IS
GOOD NEWS THAT HE CAN BOAST
ABOUT AND PROVE TO THE WORLD
THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN GO TOE TO
TELL.
-- GO TOE TO TOE.
EMILY: LET'S TALK ABOUT
AUTOPILOT -- LOTS OF QUESTIONS
GIVEN THE INVESTIGATION GOING
INTO THE FATAL CRASH.
GOOGLE AND ALPHABET THING THEY
ARE FOCUSED ON FULLY SELF
DRIVING CARS AND NOT
SEMI-AUTONOMOUS CARS LIKE TESLA
IS WORKING ON.
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
AUTOPILOT?
DAVID: HIS BIGGEST NEWS IS HE'S
GETTING BETTER BATTERY POWER.
THEY CONTINUE TO WORK ON
AUTOPILOT AND THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO RATE TEST IT SO
THAT IT IS READY FOR PEOPLE TO
USE DOWN THE LINE WITHOUT HAVING
THEIR HANDS ON THE WHEEL.
PEOPLE HAVE TO KEEP THEIR HANDS
ON THE WHEEL WITH AUTOPILOT AND
IT'S NOT FULLY AUTONOMOUS.
NO ONE HAS WON ON THE ROAD THAT
IS FULLY AUTONOMOUS YET.
EMILY: INTERESTING NEWS COMING
FROM DELPHI AND MOBILIZE WHO SAY
THEY ARE TEAMING UP TO CREATE AN
ENTIRE SELF DRIVING SYSTEM.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN AND HOW
WOULD IT WORK?
DAVID: THIS COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT.
THE ISRAELI COMPANY MAKES
SENSORS AND CAMERAS AND MAPPING
CAPABILITIES REQUIRED FOR SELF
DRIVING CARS ARE GETTING
TOGETHER AND IT'S GOING TO BE A
LOWER TAX SYSTEM.
IT'S GOING TO BE A CAMERA ACED
SYSTEM WHICH IS A LITTLE --
CAMERA BASED SYSTEM AND THEY MAY
BE ABLE TO GET CARS TO MARKET
FASTER THAN A LOT OF BIG
COMPANIES ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE OTHER SIGNIFICANCE IS
SMALLER COMPANIES LIKE SUBARU
AND MAZDA, THOSE THAT DO NOT
HAVE THE BIG BOX TO PUT INTO BIG
SELF DRIVING PROGRAMS LIKE
GENERAL MOTORS OR GOOGLE, THEY
COULD ACTUALLY GET A CRACK AT
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
IT IS ALMOST AN OPEN SOURCE
VERSION.
EMILY: WOULD THIS BE A ONE-STOP
SHOP FOR SELF DRIVING CARS?
DAVID: IT COULD BE BECAUSE THEY
WILL DO BUSINESS WITH ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO USE THEIR WHITMAN AND
GET IT ON THE ROAD QUICKLY.
EMILY: DAVID WELCH JOINING US
FROM DETROIT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT OF A.
SOMETHING WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW -- FOR THAT UPDATE.
LAST WEEK, WE FOUND OUT
PITTSBURGH IS UBER'S CITY OF
CHOICE WHERE THEY WILL RIDE
SPECIALLY FITTED VOLVO SUVS THAT
WILL BE SUPERVISED BY HUMANS IN
THE DRIVERS SEAT FOR THE TIME
BEING.
I SAT DOWN WITH THE CITY'S MAYOR
AND ASKED WHEN HE FIRST STARTED
SPEAKING WITH UBER.
SUVS THAT
WILL BE SUPERVISED BY HUMANS IN
THE DRIVERSGUEST: THE INITIAL CS
HAPPENED ALMOST 18 MONTHS AGO.
TRAVIS AND HIS TEAM HAD THEN
LOOKING FOR A CITY TO CREATE AN
INNOVATION CENTER FOR AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES.
THEY STARTED TALKING WITH
CARNEGIE MELLON UNIVERSITY AND
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PAST SIX
MONTHS, WE'VE BEEN ADVANCING THE
DRIVERLESS CARS IN LIMITED AREAS
OF THE CITY AND OVER THE COURSE
OF THE PAST FEW WEEKS, WE TOOK
IT TO THAT NEXT LEVEL TO
ACTUALLY CALL IT UP ON YOUR APP
AND USE IT ON AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES.
EMILY: WHY DO YOU WANT
PITTSBURGH TO BE THE GUINEA PIG?
IT'S EXCITING BUT IT IS ALSO
UNPROVEN.
GUEST: IT IS AND IT ISN'T.
FOR OVER A DECADE, PITTSBURGH
HAS BEEN USING DRIVERLESS CARS
AND UBER HAS IN ALL OVER THE
CITY WITH IT.
I GOT TO BE THE FIRST PERSON TO
USE THE VEHICLE ITSELF, ENDING A
NIGHT BY HAVING TRAVIS AND HIS
TEAM PICKED ME UP AND TAKE ME
HOME.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE IN A CAR
AND AT THE SAME TIME, SAFETY IS
COMING FIRST.
IT WILL ALREADY HAVE A DRIVER IN
THE DRIVER SEAT.
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN
THEREFORE SOMETIMES AND THIS HAS
BEEN THE TIME TO TAKE IT TO THE
STREETS.
EMILY: HAVE YOU TOLD THEM?
GUEST: THIS IS AN ISSUE WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH NOT JUST WITH
UBER BUT THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
SECRETARY FOX AND HIS TEAM, ONE
OF THE ISSUES WE HAVE WORKED ON
IS CYBER SECURITY.
UBER IS USING A LOT OF CYBER
SECURITY EXPERTISE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
PUTTING REQUIREMENTS THAT LOOK
AT SAFETY FIRST.
WHETHER IT IS INOCULATIONS,
WHETHER IT WAS AVIATION OR NOW
WITH MOBILITY AND AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES, THERE'S ALWAYS A TEST
TIME AND IT HAS POSITIVES AND
NEGATIVES THAT COME WITH IT.
EMILY: GIVE US SOME LEGAL
CLARITY ON HOW THIS WILL WORK.
HOW DOES THE CITY SEE UBER'S
CARS TODAY?
GUEST: PRESENTLY THERE ARE A
THOMAS VEHICLES ON THE -- THERE
ARE AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ON THE
STREET.
EVERY CAR BEING PRODUCED RIGHT
NOW, EVERY CAR COMING OUT OF
DETROIT AND RUN THE WORLD IS
BEING EQUIPPED WITH SENSORS.
THOSE CARS WILL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SPEAK WITH EACH OTHER AND
PRESENTLY, THEY COULD ALREADY DO
IT.
THE VEHICLES COULD ALSO BE
TALKING TO TRAFFIC WILL THEN
THERE WILL BE SENT SORES THAT
THESE WILL PUT UP -- THAT CITIES
-- THERE WILL BE SENSORS THAT
CITIES WILL PUT UP.
IT'S A RADICAL CHANGE IN THE WAY
WE VIEW URBAN TRANSPORTATION.
EMILY: YOU MENTION THAT THERE
WILL BE TWO DRIVERS IN THE CAR.
AT SOME POINT WILL IT BE LEGAL
TO DRIVE WITHOUT THE SAFETY
DRIVER?
IS THIS A JOB KILLER OR JOB
CREATOR?
GUEST: IN PITTSBURGH, UBER HAS
EMPLOYED 500 PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD TO WORK ON THIS PROJECT.
I ANTICIPATE OVER A THOUSAND
PEOPLE WILL BE EMPLOYED AS YOU
SEE THE TRANSITION FROM HEAVY
INDUSTRY 30 YEARS AGO AND THE
CITY THAT ONE THROUGH ECONOMIC
COLLAPSE, YOU SEE A NEW CITY
EMERGE WERE UBER, GOOGLE,
MICROSOFT, DISNEY, OCULUS, APPLE
AND ALL OF THESE COMPANIES ARE
CREATING A GLOBAL INNOVATION
CENTER IN PITTSBURGH.
THE CITIES THAT GET OUT FRONT
WILL BE THE LEADERS AND THEY
WILL BE THE CITIES WERE OTHER
COMPANIES WILL LOCATE AND WHERE
THE TALENT WILL LOCATE.
WHAT I WANT TO SEE HAPPEN IN
PITTSBURGH IS THAT WE NOT ONLY
BUILD THE TECHNOLOGY BUT START
MANUFACTURING THE PARTS AS WELL.
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING WILL BE A
CRITICAL COMPONENT IN BUILDING
AN INDUSTRY FOR ALL.
EMILY: THAT WAS THE MAYOR OF
PITTSBURGH.
AS THE BATTLE FOR THE RIDE
HAILING CUSTOMER HEATS UP,
HERE'S A STATISTIC -- UBER IS
THE MOST USED TAXI APP AND 108
COUNTRIES.
171 COUNTRIES -- THE APPS
INSTALLED ON 100% OF -- UBER HAS
STRUGGLED IN ASIA OR LOCAL
OPERATORS REIGN SUPREME.
COMING UP, WE WILL HEAR FROM A
CEO THAT WENT FROM BURNING OVER
$2 MILLION MONTH TO OPERATING IN
THE BLACK.
PLUS WHAT QUESTIONS DO YOU HAVE
FOR THE REDDIT COFOUNDERS?
WE WILL ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
LIVE RIGHT HERE ON BLOOMBERG
WEST.
THIS IS BLOOMBERG.
♪
EMILY: A STOCK WE ARE WATCHING
-- SHARES OF INTUIT FALLING IN
EXTENDED TRADING AFTER THE
COMPANY RELEASED EARNINGS THAT
BEAT ESTIMATES BUT FEATURED A
DOWNBEAT OUTLOOK.
THE MAKER OF -- A HUGE MISS FOR
THE ESTIMATES.
TO ANOTHER STOCK WE ARE
WATCHING, CHECK OUT SHARES OF
BEST BUY SURGING AS MUCH AS 19%
FOR ITS BIGGEST GAIN IN A YEAR.
SIGNALING TO INVESTORS THAT THE
CEO'S TURNAROUND PLAN MIGHT BE
PAYING OFF.
THEY HAVE BEEN BIT HARD BY
ONLINE SHOPPING AND WEAKENING
DEMAND.
BEST BUY SITE 24% INCREASE IN
ONLINE SALES IN THE SAME TIME AS
THE PRIME DAY SALES EVENT.
BEST BUY CITED A BOOST IN
WEARABLE SALES THAT HELPED TO
LIFT SHARES OF FIT BIT AND GOPRO
AS WELL.
NOT LONG AGO, JOINING THE
UNICORN CLUB WAS THE MOST SOUGHT
AFTER DRAGGING RIGHT IN SILICON
VALLEY.
STARTUPS ARE EAGER TO SIMPLY
PROCLAIM THEIR PROFITABILITY.
HOTEL TONIGHT CAN CLAIM THAT
TITLE.
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW THAT WENT
FROM BURNING MILLIONS TO
PLANNING AN IPO.
JOINING ME HERE TO DISCUSS IT IS
THE CEO, SAM SHAKE.
YOU'VE GONE FROM BURNING
MILLIONS TO OPERATING IN THE
BLACK.
HOW DID YOU DO IT?
SAM: WE DECIDED TO FOCUS ON
PROFITABILITY.
WE WANTED TO OWN OUR OWN
DESTINY.
WE WERE IN A CLIMATE THAT WAS
CHANGING FAST AND DRAMATICALLY
FROM FUNDRAISING AND WE WERE
ABLE TO RAISE A LOT OF MONEY AND
THEN WE SAW THAT PULLBACK.
WE SAID WE ARE GOING TO OWN OUR
OWN DESTINY AND MAKE THAT THE
SOLE FOCUS OF THE COMPANY.
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE FOCUS AND
FROM THAT CAME A TON OF TACTICS
WHICH WE COULD SPEND HOURS
TALKING ABOUT.
WE REDUCED ALLIANCE ON COUPONS
AND DISCOUNTING.
HOTELS GIVE US ROOM THAT WOULD
GO UNSOLD.
IT'S GREAT VALUES FOR CUSTOMERS
AND THE BEST PRICES OUT THERE,
ABSOLUTELY.
WE WOULD SUPPLEMENT THAT FOR
TRYING HOTEL TONIGHT AND THE
PRODUCT STOOD ON ITS OWN.
WE DID NOT HAVE TO PROVIDE THAT
DISCOUNT AND WE WERE JUST
CANNIBALIZING THE EXISTING
SALES.
GROWTH CONTINUED AND IN MANY
CASES ACCELERATED.
EMILY: DID YOU END UP
FUNDRAISING?
SAM: WE DID NOT NEED TO.
WE HIT IT IN APRIL AND WE WERE
ABLE TO ANNOUNCE PUBLICLY THAT
WE ACHIEVED THAT GOAL.
EMILY: YOU SAY YOU ARE PLANNING
TO GO PUBLIC BY THE END OF THE
NEXT YEAR.
WALK ME THROUGH THE NEXT 12
MONTHS OR SO.
SAM: I TALKED TO OUR ADVISORS
AND WOULD -- SAID WHAT IS THE
NEXT GOAL?
I'M VERY COMPETITIVE AND HAVE
ALWAYS ONE TO GO PUBLIC AND HAVE
A COMPANY I STARTED AND TAKE IT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
THAT'S WHEN I WAS 22 YEARS OLD.
I'M PERSONALLY VERY MOTIVATED BY
THAT AND I THINK IT WOULD BE A
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE FOR THE
TEAM TO GO THROUGH.
THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP FOR
CONTROLLING OUR DESTINY AND WE
THINK WE CAN GET THERE BEFORE
THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
EMILY: OFTEN THE FINANCES OF
SILICON VALLEY PROJECTS ARE
CLOSELY HELD.
WHY ARE YOU BEING SO PUBLIC
ABOUT THIS?
SAM: IF I LOOKED FOR US TO BE
PUBLIC ONE DAY, THE INFORMATION
IS GOING TO BE SHARED THAN OR AS
WE GET CLOSE TO GOING PUBLIC IS
EVEN MORE THAN WHAT WE ARE
SHARING RIGHT NOW.
I WANT THE WORLD TO KNOW THAT
EVEN THOUGH WE WENT THROUGH SOME
DIFFICULT TIMES, WE ARE THRIVING
RIGHT NOW.
WE DID NOT DO THAT AT THE
EXPENSE OF GROWTH.
WE HAVE A GREAT PIPELINE COMING
OUT OF THE FALL, SO I LOVE TO
TALK ABOUT IT AND IT'S FUN TO
TALK ABOUT AND BRAG ABOUT THE
GREAT WORK THE TEAM IS DOING.
EMILY: WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
THEM AND THEY INTACT.
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO A SALE?
SAM: WE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON
GROWTH AND MAINTAINING
PROFITABILITY, FOCUSED A LOT ON
INNOVATION.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THINGS WE CAN
CONTROL THE DESTINY OF, WHICH,
FOR US IS A PUBLIC OFFERING.
I THINK THE MARKETS WILL COME
BACK WITHIN THE TIMEFRAME WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND IF NOT, WE WILL
HAVE THE POSITION TO HOLD OUT AS
LONG AS NEEDED.
EMILY: EXPEDIA AND PRICELINE
DOMINATE THE MARKET.
THERE GROSS BOOKINGS ARE 100
TIMES WHAT HOTEL TONIGHT'S ARE.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK YOU CAN
MAKE IT AS A PUBLIC COMPANY?
SAM: WE ARE FOCUSED SOLELY ON
LAST MINUTE, THE TEMPORAL
DIMENSION.
WE ARE ACTUALLY A WEEK IN
ADVANCE, SO WE HAVE 50% OF THE
MARKET OPPORTUNITY RIGHT THERE.
AND WE ARE MOBILE ONLY.
THAT CUTS THE MARKET DOWN
CONSIDERABLY.
THE OTHER GUYS SELL CRUISES AND
FLIGHTS.
OUR REVENUES RIGHT NOW ARE YOUR
TODAY GROWING COMPARED TO 15%
FOR OUR COMPETITORS.
WHEN PEOPLE SEE THE PRODUCT AND
A VALUE PROPOSITION WE OFFER, WE
SEE THEM COME BACK OVER AND OVER
AGAIN EVEN THOUGH GROSS BOOKINGS
WE HAVE ARE SMALLER, OUR
MARKETING COSTS ARE FAR SMALLER
THAN THEIRS.
EMILY: WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE TO
OTHER STARTUPS THAT MAY BE IN
THE POSITION YOU WERE SIX MONTHS
AGO?
SAM: WHEN I LOOK BACK ON IT, I
THOUGHT IT WAS A MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE DECISION.
WE AS A TEAM SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE IMPROVE
UNIT ECONOMICS AND KEEP PROFIT
ABILITY AT THAT TRANSACTION
BASIS IN PLACE AND HAVE THE
LEVERAGE TO PULL BACK IF NEEDED?
IT WAS NOT A BINARY DECISION.
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING WE LOOK
AT TOGETHER.
IF A COMPANY IS LOOKING THAT
WAY, THEY WILL BE POSITIONED FOR
SUCCESS.
EMILY: GOOD TO HEAR HOW YOU
LEARN FROM YOUR OWN EXPERIENCES.
RATE TO HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW.
-- GREAT TO HAVE YOUR THE SHOW.
UP NEXT, WE WILL LOOK AT WHAT IS
TO BLAME FOR MOST FLIGHT DELAYS.
IT'S NOT THE WEATHER.
THIS IS BLOOMBERG.
♪
EMILY: SOME TOUGH NEWS FOR
E-COMMERCE RETAILER, ONE KINGS
LANE.
AFTER IT WAS VALUED AT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS, IT WENT FOR
LESS THAN $30 MILLION IN ITS
SALE TO BED, BATH AND BEYOND.
THIS COMES AFTER TWO SUCCESSFUL
E-COMMERCE ACQUISITIONS.
WALMART'S PURCHASE OF JET AND
UNILEVER'S DEAL WITH DOLLAR
SHAVE CLUB.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, DELTA
SUFFERED THE WRATH OF THOUSANDS
OF ANGRY TRAVELERS WHEN IT
DISCLOSED A SINGLE POWER OUTAGE
CRASHED ITS SYSTEM AND LEAD TO
2000 FLIGHT CANCELLATIONS.
ANOTHER COMPUTER FAILURE AT
SOUTHWEST IN JULY LED TO 2300
CANCELLATIONS AND WILL COST THE
CARRIER TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
ARE THESE KINDS OF DELAYS
HAPPENING MORE OFTEN?
WHO IS TO BLAME?
OUR AVIATION REPORTER HAS BEEN
LOOKING INTO THE CAUSE OF MOST
U.S. FLIGHT DELAYS AND JOINS US
FROM WASHINGTON WITH ALL OF
THOSE DETAILS.
IT USED TO BE THE WEATHER AND
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL THAT CAUSED
THE PROBLEMS.
NOW YOU SAY THAT IT IS JUST
AIRLINES.
HOW OFTEN ARE COMPUTER GLITCHES
CAUSING PROBLEMS?
GUEST: THE COMPUTER PROBLEMS WE
HAVE SEEN, DEVASTATING AS IT WAS
FOR THOSE PEOPLE ARE PROBABLY
NOT BIGGEST CAUSE OF DELAYS.
IT'S A MORE MUNDANE MIX OF
AIRCRAFT AT THE WRONG PLACE,
MAINTENANCE PROBLEMS, PILOTS WHO
MAY HAVE WORKED TOO MANY HOURS
AND CANNOT CONTINUE, THINGS LIKE
THAT.
BUT IT IS TRUE THAT AIRLINES
LIKE A LOT OF HIS THIS IS OUR
VERY RELIANT ON THEIR COMPUTERS
AND SO WHEN THEY DO GO DOWN, IT
CAN BE DEVASTATING.
EMILY: WHY IS THE TECHNOLOGY
USED BY AIRLINES SO OUT AIDED?
ALAN: YOU COULD ARGUE BOTH SIDES
OF THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A COMPUTER CRASH, IT
IS OUTDATED.
AT THE AIRPLANES THEM SELVES AND
THE AIR TRAFFIC SYSTEM, IN SPITE
OF WHAT CRITICS SAY, IS QUITE A
SOPHISTICATED, INTERLOCKING
NETWORK OF COMPUTERS.
IT'S QUITE IMPRESSIVE IF YOU
CONSIDER WHAT IT DOES AND ITS
SAFETY RECORD, WHICH IS REALLY
AMAZING.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A FATAL ACCIDENT
ON A U.S. CARRIER IN YEARS AND
YEARS.
SO THAT IS IN THE BACKDROP OF
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
THE RELIABILITY IS QUITE
AMAZING.
EMILY: DELTA IRONICALLY HAS THE
BEST ON-TIME RECORD OF ANY
CARRIER.
SHOULD WE BE CONCERNED THAT
SAFETY WAS IN QUESTION WITH
THESE ISSUES?
ALAN: I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION THAT SAFETY WAS
COMPROMISED WITH THE COMPUTER
OUTAGE.
THE REASON THEY ARE PUTTING
THEIR PLANES ON THE GROUND IS TO
BE CAUTIOUS.
SO THAT'S NOT REALLY A CONCERN
AND IT IS WORN OUT WHY THE
ACCIDENT STATISTICS WE SEE
WORLDWIDE, WHICH ARE AMAZING
COMPARED TO 20 OR 30 YEARS AGO.
RELIABILITY IS ANOTHER QUESTION
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT HERE.
EMILY: WHAT'S THE SOLUTION?
WHAT ARE AIRLINES DOING AND WHAT
ARE THEY GETTING BETTER AT?
ALAN: THE DATA WE LOOKED AT
SHOWED DELAYS CAUSED BY THE
AIRLINES HAVE EXCEEDED THOSE
CAUSED BY WEATHER AND THAT SORT
OF THING.
IT DOESN'T SHOW WHAT HAS CAUSED
THE ACCIDENT, WHICH IS A LITTLE
TRICKY TO TALK ABOUT.
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF COMPANIES
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
BANKRUPTCIES AND HAVE CUT COSTS
AND STAFF, HAVE LOWERED THE
SALARIES OF A LOT OF THEIR STAFF
AND I THINK WHAT THAT HAS DONE
IS CUT INTO THE RELIABILITY OF
SOME OF THEIR SYSTEMS.
THE WAY TO IMPROVE THAT IS TO
ADD EXTRA AIRCRAFT SO IF ONE
AIRCRAFT ARRIVES LATE, YOU CAN
THROW IN A SUBSTITUTE.
THAT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
SUBSTITUTE.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THEY CAN
DO TO TRY TO SPEED THINGS UP.
EMILY: OUR AVIATION REPORTER
JOINING US FROM WASHINGTON, D C.
COMING UP, WE WILL SPEAK WITH
THE COFOUNDERS OF REDDIT.
WE'RE TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS LIVE
ON REDDIT.
♪
MARK: I'M MARK CRUMPTON.
LET'S GET A CHECK ON YOUR FIRST
WORD NEWS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAS
RECEIVED A FORMAL OR -- A FORMAL
EXHIBITION REQUEST.
THE TURKISH PRESIDENT HAS BLAMED
THE ATTEMPTED COUP ON THE MAN
WHO LIVES IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS THE
REQUEST IS UNRELATED TO THE
FAILED COUP.
FLORIDA HAS CONFIRMED FIVE
NON-TRAVEL RELATED INCIDENTS OF
ZIKA.
THE FLORIDA GOVERNOR SAYS FOR
NEW CASES ARE RELATED TO
MOSQUITOES IN THE WYNWOOD ARTS
DISTRICT.
THE FIFTH WAS DIAGNOSED IN A
RESIDENT WHO HAS NOT TRAVELED
INTERNATIONALLY.
HEALTH OFFICIALS ANNOUNCED FIVE
CASES OF THE GODLY TO MOSQUITOES
IN MIAMI BEACH.
GREEN PARTY CANDIDATE, JILL
STEIN, SAYS SHE COULD WIN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IF SHE
COULD JUST RECEIVE MORE PUBLIC
EXPOSURE.
SHE SAYS VOTERS DESERVE TO HEAR
FROM ALL THE CANDIDATES.
THE COMMISSION ON PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATES SAYS CANDIDATES MUST
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF AT LEAST 15%
OF VOTERS TO BE INCLUDED.
SHE HAS BEEN PULLING IN THE LOW
SINGLE DIGITS.
GLOBAL NEWS 24 HOURS A DAY
POWERED BY OVER 2600 JOURNALISTS
AND ANALYSTS IN MORE THAN 120
COUNTRIES.
I'M MARK CRUMPTON, THIS IS
BLOOMBERG.
IT'S JUST AFTER 6:30 HERE IN NEW
YORK.
I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE, PAUL
ALLEN, WITH A LOOK AT THE
MARKETS.
PAUL: NEW ZEALAND TRADING NOW
FOR 30 MINUTES ON WEDNESDAY AND
IS OFF SLIGHTLY, ABOUT .1%
DESPITE A HEALTHY LEAD FROM
NIKKEI FUTURES TRADING OUT OF
CHICAGO LOOKING FLAT.
SOME SLIGHT GAINS HERE IN
AUSTRALIA.
A MAJOR STOCK IN FOCUS WILL BE
QANTAS AND AS I SPEAK, THOSE
RESULTS ARE CROSSING THE
BLOOMBERG.
IF WE LOOK AT THE UNDERLYING
PRETEXT PROFIT, $1.53 BILLION.
1.57 WAS EXPECTED.
THE BIG NEWS -- THEY'RE GOING TO
RESTART PAYING A DIVIDEND.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN SEVEN
YEARS, QANTAS SHAREHOLDERS WILL
GET A DIVIDEND OF SEVEN CENTS
PER SHARE.
THE OLD AIRCRAFT HAVE BEEN
RETIRED, WAGES WERE FROZEN -- A
LOT OF PAIN OVER THE YEARS BUT
THE DIVIDEND IS RETURNING.
WEST FARM IS UP WITH RESULTS AND
IN CHINA, LOOK AT ENERGY STOCKS.
WE WILL LOOK FOR THEM TO BE HIT
I WEEK ENERGY PRICES -- HIT BY
WEEK ENERGY PRICES.
I'M PAUL ALLEN IN SYDNEY,
AUSTRALIA.
EMILY: THIS IS BLOOMBERG WEST.
I'M EMILY CHANG.
WELCOME TO OUR SPECIAL ON
REDDIT.
OVER THE NEXT HALF HOUR, WE WILL
ANSWER THE DOZENS OF QUESTIONS
POSTED IN THE LAST WEEK WITH
TOPICS RANGING FROM WORK AND
LIFE BALANCE.
BUT FIRST WE HAVE TO DISCUSS
REDDIT AS A BUSINESS.
FIRST FROM GETTING REJECTED BY
WHY COMBINATION ARE TOO
CONVINCING THE CEO TO CHANGE HIS
MIND.
THE SITE HOSTS OVER 240 MILLION
ACT OF USERS AND 340,000 POSTS A
DAY, BUT THEY BELIEVE IT CAN BE
SO MUCH MORE.
JOINING US NOW ARE TWO OF THE
REDDIT COFOUNDERS.
YOU CAME BACK AS CEO LAST YEAR
AND YOU CAME BACK AS STRATEGY
OFFICER.
YOU GUYS HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER
SINCE MOVING DAY AT UVA.
YOU HAVE AN TOGETHER A LONG
TIME.
GUEST: 15 YEARS.
GUEST: THAT'S A HEALTHY
MARRIAGE.
EMILY: TELL ME WHERE YOU THINK
YOU HAVE MADE THE MOST PROGRESS
AND WHERE DID THE MOST
CHALLENGES REMAIN?
GUEST: THE BIGGEST THING WE HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON IN THE LAST
YEARS BUILDING THE TEAM AT
REDDIT, GETTING THE TEAM IN A
POSITION TO BUILD AND EXECUTE
ALL OF OUR DREAMS.
WE'VE REBUILT PRETTY MUCH EVERY
TEAM AT REDDIT AND WE'VE SHIFT
-- WE'VE SHIPPED MORE IN LAST
QUARTER THAN THE ENTIRE YEAR
BEFORE THAT.
EMILY: WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST
THINGS ON THE TO DO LIST?
GUEST: WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO, BUT
WE'VE MADE A TON OF PROGRESS IN
SHORT ORDER.
THE TEAM WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER
HAS SEEN A VAST IMPROVEMENT IN
MOBILE WEB AND THERE'S MORE ROOM
TO GO.
THEY'RE CERTAINLY MORE USER
EXPERIENCE IMPROVEMENTS, BUT THE
GROWTH SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
EMILY: WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT GROWTH AND THE USER
EXPERIENCE, BUT I WANTED TO
START ON THE BUSINESS.
WE HAVE BEEN TAKING QUESTIONS
FROM REDDIT.
ONE OF THE FIRST -- LOOKING
FORWARD TO HOW YOU PLAN TO
MONETIZE REDDIT COMMUNITY AND
HOW HAS THE PRESSURE TO BECOME
PROFITABLE CHANGE THE WAY WEB
BUSINESSES ARE OPERATED NOW?
GUEST: THE FIRST PART IS HOW DO
WE MONETIZE AND THAT IS AT STOP
WE'VE EXPLORED A BUNCH OF IS
THIS MODELS BUT ADDS MAKE THE
MOST SENSE FOR US.
IT'S A SPACE WE WERE ALREADY
LIVING IN AND THAT HAS BEEN
GETTING BETTER AND BETTER.
EMILY: GIVE ME SOME COLOR ON
THAT.
GUEST: ADVERTISING ON REDDIT IS
DIFFERENT THAN ELSEWHERE YOU
IT'S THE LIFE BECAUSE YOUR
INTERACTIONS ARE DIFFERENT.
AND ADVERTISER ELSEWHERE ONLINE
OR OFF-LINE, THEY ARE YELLING AT
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
YOU ARE TRYING TO SAY YOUR
MESSAGE IN THE FLASHES THEM
LOUDEST WAY POSSIBLE.
ON REDDIT, YOU CAN MAKE A
GENUINE CONNECTION.
IT'S MORE AKIN TO SPEAKING TO A
CUSTOMER IN THEIR HOME.
WHEN AN ADVERTISER EMBRACES THAT
IN SPEAKS TO THEIR CUSTOMER
AUTHENTICALLY, YOU CAN GET A
REAL CONNECTION.
EMILY: HERE'S ANOTHER -- ARE YOU
WORRIED ABOUT COMPETITION?
REDDIT HAS GONE UNCHANGED AND
UNOPPOSED FOR A DECADE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED SOMEONE COULD
SWEEP AWAY NONCORE USERS THE
SAME WAY REDDIT DID TO DIGG IN
2010?
GUEST: WE ARE SO FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING A GREAT USER
EXPERIENCE -- WE WOULD NOT GO ON
SOME KIND OF FOOL THEIR UNLIKE
OTHER STARTUPS HAVE MADE IN THE
PAST.
EMILY: BUT THERE'S SO MUCH
COMPETITION -- EVERYTHING FROM
TWITTER TO FACEBOOK TO SNAPCHAT
--
GUEST: ONE OF THE BEST PIECES OF
ADVICE I WAS GIVEN EARLY IN OUR
NEAR -- IN OUR CAREER IS THAT IF
YOU SPEND SO MUCH TIME LOOKING
IN THE REARVIEW MIRROR, YOU WILL
DRIVE INTO A WALL.
WE JUST LOOK AT THE FUTURE OF
REDDIT AND THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN
OUR GUIDING LIGHT AND HAS SERVED
AS WELL.
EMILY: LIKE MANY WEBSITES,
REDDIT'S I MARRY BUSINESS MODEL
IS BEING CHALLENGED BY AD
BLOCKING SOFTWARE.
WHAT IS GOING TO YOUR MIND AS
YOU BATTLE THIS SHIFT AND HOW TO
KEEP THE BUSINESS FORWARD FACING
AND AGILE?
GUEST: NEVER LOSE TRACK OF WILD
USERS ARE COMING TO YOUR SITE.
IF YOU START SACRIFICING THAT,
YOU WILL START HAVING A BAD
TIME.
ONE OF THE HUGE ASSETS WE HAVE
IS THIS IS THE ZEITGEIST FOR A
QUARTER OF A BILLION PEOPLE.
AND IT IS A BRAND POT STREAM
COME TRUE BECAUSE WORD-OF-MOUTH
IS THE MOST POWERFUL FORM OF
ADVERTISING.
EMILY: HOW DO YOU BALANCE BEING
TRUE TO THE USER AND NOT LETTING
THINGS GET OUT OF CONTROL AND
TURNING THIS INTO A REAL
BUSINESS?
THAT HAS BEEN THE MAIN CHALLENGE
OVER THE LAST YEARS.
GUEST: YES AND NO.
THERE'S A WAY TO ADVERTISE ON
REDDIT THAT'S NOT ATTRACTIVE RUM
THE USER EXPERIENCE.
LIKE WHEN YOU MAKE A REAL
CONNECTION.
CUSTOMERS EXIST BECAUSE THEY
NEED SOMETHING FROM THE BRAND.
THAT AND BE A POWERFUL THING.
WE TRY TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
DO THAT A WAY THAT DOESN'T
DISTRACT FROM THE PROJECT --
FROM THE PRODUCT.
SO THAT THEY ARE NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE EXPERIENCE BUT
NEUTRAL OR POSITIVE GUEST:.
REDDIT IS IN A FORTUNATE
POSITION BECAUSE A BRAND LIKE
COCA-COLA CAN RUN AN AD ON
REDDIT AND DURING THE SUPER
BOWL, AND ADD ABOUT AN AD AND
ENGAGEMENT ON THAT WAS HIGHER
ENGAGEMENT THAN CONTENT ON
REDDIT.
THEY CAN MAKE A GREAT INVESTMENT
THAT THEY ARE ALSO MAKING A REAL
INFLUENCE.
EMILY: CONDE NAST. YOU GUYS IN
2006 AND SPUN YOU OFF IN 2011.
DO YOU WISH OVER THE LAST DECADE
THEY HAD HELP YOU BUILD UP THE
BUSINESS?
GUEST: IN A LOT OF RESPECTS,
THEY WERE.
WHEN WE SOLD THE COMPANY IN
2006, WE WERE BOTH 22.
WE DIDN'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT
RUNNING THE BUSINESS.
AT THE TIME, I REGRETTED IT.
THIS THING KEEPS GROWING AND WE
DID NEED TO SELL.
BUT WHEN I REFLECT ON IT NOW,
THAT IT WAS A GOOD HOME FOR US
TO LEARN HOW TO OPERATE BUSINESS
AND LEARN HOW TO MANAGE AND
GROW.
NOW THAT WE ARE INDEPENDENT
AGAIN, WE CAN BRING THOSE
LESSONS BACK.
I'M NOT CERTAIN REDDIT WOULD
HAVE SURVIVED WITHOUT IT.
IT'S NOT A SURE THING.
I THINK EVERYTHING PLAYED OUT
THE WELL.
EMILY: STAY WITH US.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK MORE ABOUT
THE USER EXPERIENCE IN THIS
EXCLUSIVE CONVERSATION WITH
REDDIT'S PRIVACY POLICY AND DO
NOT TRACK TOOLS.
♪
EMILY: REDDIT'S STANCE ON
INTERNET PRIVACY AND FREE SPEECH
HAS MADE A PIONEER.
LAST YEAR, IT ROLLED OUT ITS DO
NOT TRACK TECHNOLOGY, BUT THE
COMPANY HAS ITS CRITICS WHO CALL
IT A BREEDING GROUND FOR TROLLS.
HERE WITH ME ARE TWO OF THE
REDDIT COFOUNDERS.
I KNOW YOU HAVE WORKED HARD TO
CHANGE THIS BUT DO YOU THINK
TROLLS ARE HUGE PROBLEM?
GUEST: IN THE LAST QUARTER,
WE'VE REDUCED SPAM BY 90% AND
ABUSE BY 30%.
EMILY: HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
IT'S DIFFICULT TO CRACK DOWN
WITHOUT PISSING PEOPLE OFF.
GUEST: ON SPAM, IT'S FINDING
WHERE IT'S COMING FROM AND
ILLUMINATING IT.
ABUSE, LETTING USERS BLOCK OTHER
USERS HAS HAD A BIG IMPACT.
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO BUT WE
ARE MAKING STEADY PROGRESS.
GUEST: TWO-PUTTED IN
PERSPECTIVE, QUARTER OF A
BILLION PEOPLE WILL HIT REDDIT
THIS MONTH, A POPULATION LARGER
THAN BRAZIL.
OF ALL THE CONTENT THEY ARE
PRODUCING, ONLY .02% GETS
REPORTED.
IN THAT CONTEXT, IT'S A
REMARKABLE ENVIRONMENT.
EMILY: SOME OF THE CRITICISM
GOES BEYOND THIS -- THEY SAY
IT'S A WAY TO ORGANIZE TROLLS
AND SPREAD ACROSS THE INTERNET.
THIS IS WHAT ELLEN PAO TRIED TO
CRACK DOWN ON.
IT DID NOT END WELL FOR HER.
SHE DID ULTIMATELY LEAVE.
HOW ARE YOU BALANCING NOT
ALIENATING YOUR CORE USERS AND
CLEANING UP THE SITE?
GUEST: OUR CORE USERS ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY GOOD AND POSITIVE
.
WE'VE ILLUMINATED NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES OVER THE LAST YEAR.
SOME OF IT MORE DRAMATIC THAN
OTHERS.
BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE SET THE
COMMUNITY WITH WHAT IS
ACCEPTABLE AND WHAT IS NOT, IT'S
BECOME EASIER.
IT'S ABOUT SETTING BOUNDARIES
AND ENFORCING IT CONSISTENTLY.
THAT'S THE NAME OF THE GAME.
EMILY: IN THE WEEK LEADING UP TO
THIS, WE WERE TAKING QUESTIONS
ON REDDIT AND A LOT OF USERNAMES
WERE TOO OFFENSIVE TO USE.
SOME OF THEM INVOLVED MY NAME.
HOW ARE YOU MAKING REDDIT SAFER
FOR WOMEN IN PARTICULAR?
GUEST: IT IS A BIG THING ON OUR
MINDS NEAR CONSTANTLY.
OUR VISION IS TO MAKE REDDIT AS
USER-FRIENDLY AS POSSIBLE.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK WE'RE
DOING, CONNECTING PEOPLE WITH
THEIR HOME ON REDDIT.
IT'S NOT AN EASY PROBLEM, BUT I
THINK WE HAVE MADE STRIDES
TOWARD IT.
THERE IS STILL PLENTY OF WORK TO
BE DONE.
EMILY: AND IT'S NOT JUST WOMEN,
BUT MINORITIES AND ANYONE IS NOT
A STRAIGHT WHITE GUY.
GUEST: ACCORDING TO RECENT DATA,
49% OF REDDIT OR ARE WOMEN.
ONE OF THREE WOMEN WILL HIT
REDDIT THIS MONTH.
IT'S A LARGE AND DIVERSE
POPULATION AND WE ARE DOING A
BETTER JOB EVERY DAY.
WE DID NOT HAVE A TRUST AND
SAFETY TEAM ONE YEAR AGO AND WE
DO NOW.
IT'S MAKING SURE PEOPLE GET THE
SAFE EXPERIENCE THEY WANT.
GUEST: ONE OF THE LARGEST
WOMEN'S COMMUNITIES ONLINE IS ON
REDDIT.
EMILY: REDDIT HAS TAKEN SOME
STRONG STANDS ON THE MATTER OF
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN THE FIELD.
WHAT BUSINESS CASE CAN YOU SHARE
THAT MAY CHANGE THE MINDS OF
THIS IS WHO HAVE NOT CAUGHT ON
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF CONSUMER
PRIVACY QUESTION MARK GUEST:
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ANY BUSINESS
TO HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
FOR US, IT'S ABOUT MAINTAINING
TRUST WITH OUR USERS.
WE ALSO THINK IT'S VERY MUCH
ABOUT MENA SITE -- MINIMIZING
THE SURFACE AREA.
WE DON'T REQUIRE E-MAIL
ADDRESSES.
IT UP FOR THE USERS TO SHARE
WHAT THEY WANT.
IF WE WERE TO GET ATTACKED BY
THAT SORT OF THING, DON'T ASK A
LOT, DON'T TAKE A LOT.
DO THE RIGHT THING FOR THEM.
THAT MAKES GOOD BUSINESS SENSE
FOR ANY COMPANY.
EMILY: HERE'S ANOTHER ONE FROM A
USERNAME THAT WE CANNOT SAY BUT
THEY DO LISTEN TO BLOOMBERG
RADIO.
HOW DOES REDDIT CHECK THE
BALANCE BETWEEN FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND PRIVACY?
GUEST: I WOULD SAY THAT PRIVACY
AND FREEDOM OF SPEECH ARE NOT
CONFLICTED.
PRIVACY IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IMPORTANT.
WE BELIEVE ANYONE ON REDDIT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES FULLY.
ON REDDIT, YOU CAN BE YOUR TRUE
SELF AND THAT'S A POWERFUL
THING.
PEOPLE COME SEEKING RELATIONSHIP
ADVICE OR HELP WOMEN HAVE
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS OR COMING OUT
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THESE ARE POWERFUL THINGS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE.
WHEN IT COMES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WE HOLD A VERY HIGH
BAR.
WE MAKE SURE REQUESTS ARE VALID
AND AUTHENTIC AND PUSH BACK WHEN
THEY ARE NOT.
IN FACT, WE DID THAT ABOUT ONE
WEEK AGO WHEN WE WERE SUED BY
ATLANTIC RECORDS FOR USER DATA.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE HAND OVER.
EMILY: REDDIT HAS BEEN KNOWN AS
THE FRONT PAGE OF THE INTERNET
AND THE IDEA IS TO TURN THIS
INTO A FULL-FLEDGED MEDIA
EMPIRE.
YOU DELVE INTO ORIGINAL CONTENT.
HOW ARE THOSE EXPERIMENTS GOING?
GUEST: WELL SO FAR.
WE HAVE DOUBLED DOWN ON
PUBLISHER TOOLS AND WE REALIZE
SO MANY PUBLISHERS, NEWSROOMS
STARTING THE DAY READING THEIR
BEATS ON REDDIT.
IF YOU COVER SCIENCE, YOU ARE
READING IT AND THEY TRIED TO
TURN THAT IN TWO CONTENT A WOULD
PUBLISH ON THEIR OWN SITE.
BY EATING DOG FOOD OURSELVES, WE
REALIZE THESE ARE THE TOOLS WE
NEED TO BE BUILDING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT BUILDS
A RELATIONSHIP WITH PEOPLE TO --
PEOPLE WHO DO THE BEST JOB.
EMILY: IN TWO YEARS, WHERE DO
YOU SEE REDDIT? GUEST: WE SHOULD
BE SIGNIFICANTLY BIGGER AND
REVENUE SHOULD BE UP
SIGNIFICANTLY AND I THINK WE
WILL MAKE PROGRESS AGAINST THE
BIGGEST PRODUCT -- BIGGEST
PROBLEM WE HAVE -- HOW DO WE
CONNECT FIRST-TIME USER WITH
THEIR HOME ON REDDIT?
I BELIEVE EVERY PERSON HAS A
HOME SOMEWHERE ON REDDIT BECAUSE
WE HAVE 45,000 ACTIVE
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S SOMETHING FOR EVERYBODY.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE WE ARE
CHASING AFTER RIGHT NOW.
GUEST: THE MAGIC BEHIND REDDIT
LAYS IN THAT PSEUDONYMITY.
YOU CAN REALLY BE YOUR.
.
YOU CAN TALK WORLD POLITICS,
LEARN ABOUT COMMUNITIES AND THE
KINDS OF CONNECTIONS PEOPLE MAKE
ON REDDIT WILL BE AS STRONG OR
STRONGER, I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
CONNECTIONS THEY MAKE ON OTHER
SOCIAL NETWORKS.
EMILY: WE WILL BE TALKING MORE
ABOUT WHY COMMENTATOR, WHERE YOU
GOT YOUR START.
IT IS A NUMBER TWO OF DEMO DAY.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK TALKING
ABOUT REDDIT.
THIS IS BLOOMBERG.
♪
EMILY: WHY COMMENTATOR'S DEMO
DAYS UNDERWAY.
REDDIT GOT ITS START AT THE
INCUBATOR 11 YEARS AGO.
ITS ORIGINAL APPLICATION OVER
THE WEEKEND ON FACEBOOK.
TALK TO US ABOUT WHY, LATER'S
ROLE IN THE EVOLUTION.
HOW INVOLVED HAVE THEY BEEN OVER
THE COURSE OF THIS 11 YEARS?
GUEST: YOU MENTIONED THAT PG DID
REJECT US.
JESSICA LIVINGSTON FOUGHT TO
BRING US BACK.
SHE'S THE REASON THAT WE GOT IN
AND WE WILL ALWAYS BE GRATEFUL.
EMILY: HERE'S A QUESTION FROM A
REDDIT USER -- HOW DID THEY HELP
YOU AND DO YOU STILL KEEP IN
TOUCH?
GUEST: IT HAS HELPED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT HE MET A LOT
OF OUR CLOSEST FRIENDS THERE AND
OUR CLOSEST BUSINESS CONFIDENCE
WERE PEOPLE THAT WE MET, THE
FOUNDERS OF WHICH WERE IN THAT
BATCH WITH US.
WE GREW UP TOGETHER AND WE
LEARNED HOW TO HIRE, FIRE AND
RAISE MONEY.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
EXPERIENCE TO HAVE.
GUEST: ESPECIALLY IN 2005.
THERE WERE NOT A LOT OF
RESOURCES AND THE SUPPORT GROUP
IT PROVIDED TO SHARE NOTES WAS
INVALUABLE AND EVEN MORE
VALUABLE TODAY BECAUSE THE
NETWORK IS SO MUCH BIGGER.
YOU MAY NOT GET A RESPONSE
INSTANTLY.
IT JUST GETS STRONGER WITH EVERY
BATCH.
EMILY: PAUL GRAHAM HAS GIVEN A
LOT OF ADVICE OVER THE YEARS.
WHAT APPLIES AND WHAT DOESN'T
MARK -- WHAT DOESN'T?
GUEST: I'M NOT GOING TO GET IN
WHAT -- INTO WHAT DOESN'T.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECES
OF ADVICE WE RECEIVED IS TO
LAUNCH AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE UNTIL YOU LAUNCH, YOU
ARE NOT LEARNING.
IT'S A DAY YOU LEARN WHETHER
YOUR IDEAS GOING TO WORK OR NOT
SO HOW YOU HAVE TO CHANGE TO
MAKE IT WORK -- I REMEMBER
BEFORE WE STARTED CODING ON
REDDIT AND IT'S NOTHING LIKE YOU
SEE TODAY, BUT WE LEARNED SO
MUCH JUST BY ITERATING.
EMILY: HOW MANY COMPANIES WERE
IN THE BATCH?
EIGHT QUESTION MARK NOW THEY ARE
FUNDING HUNDREDS OF COMPANIES
AND THEY ARE SOMETIMES
CRITICIZED AS A START UP COMPANY
THAT VALUATIONS ARE OVERINFLATED
JUST BECAUSE THEIR NAME IS
ATTACHED TO IT.
GUEST: I WAS A PARTNER FOR A
TIME THERE.
THE BENEFIT OF THOSE THREE
MONTHS IS A HUGE MULTIPLIER.
WHEN YOU CAN CALL UP AND GET
FEEDBACK AND GET SMACKED AROUND
AND FOCUSED ON WHAT MATTERS, IT
MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE AND
THOSE VALUATIONS ARE A RESULT OF
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE MUCH
BETTER OFF.
EMILY: HERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION
FROM REDDIT.
WHEN WAS THE MOMENT YOU ALMOST
GAVE UP AND WHAT OLD YOU
THROUGH?
GUEST: I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS
THE MOMENT, BUT THERE ARE MANY
MOMENTS.
WHEN YOU ARE A FOUNDER,
ESPECIALLY FIRST-TIME FOUNDER,
CHANNELING WHAT YOUR MOTIVATION
IS.
SOMETIMES IT DOING THE BEST
THING FOR OUR USERS.
SOMETIMES IT WAS NOT LETTING
ALEXIS DOWN.
I DON'T WANT TO LOOK STUPID.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHY YOU ARE WORKING.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS UP TO YOUR
MOTIVATION.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS AM GOING TO
CHANGE THE WORLD.
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE AN UP,
THERE'S A DOWN.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO GET
THROUGH AND JUST GO ALONG WITH
THE RIGHT.
EMILY: LAST CLICK QUESTION -- IF
YOU HAD $40,000 AND YOU ARE
GOING TO START OVER, WHAT WOULD
YOU DO?
GUEST: WE STARTED REDDIT WITH
12,000 AND WE WOULD DO ABOUT THE
SAME THING.
EMILY: THE CHIEF STRATEGY OFFERS
HER AND CEO OF REDDIT.
THANK YOU FOR STOPPING BY.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
THAT DOES IT FOR THIS EDITION OF
"BLOOMBERG WEST."
TUNE IN FOR FULL COVERAGE OF HP
EARNINGS TOMORROW.
THAT'S ALL FOR TODAY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
THIS IS BLOOMBERG.
♪
>> FROM OUR STUDIOS IN NEW YORK
CITY, THIS IS "CHARLIE ROSE."
-- BRIAN STEPHENSON IS HERE.
HIS EFFORTS HAVE ALSO FOCUSED ON
PUTTING A SPOTLIGHT ON THE
LEGACY OF SLAVERY IN AMERICA.
HE IS ALSO ONE A LANDMARK
SUPREME COURT RULING.
THE NEW ORGANIZATION PLANS TO
OPEN THE LARGEST MEMORIAL
HONORING THE THOUSANDS OF
VICTIMS OF LYNCHING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PROJECT INCLUDES A MUSEUM.
BOTH WILL BE LOCATED IN
MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA.
I AM PLEASED TO HAVE HIM BACK AT
THE STABLE WELCOME.
WHEN HE WENT TO MONTGOMERY AS A
YOUNG BOY ARE, DID YOU SEE THIS
CAREER HAPPENING?
BRIAN: I DIDN'T SEE EVERYTHING
THAT WOULD COME.